dans les rues de L'Haÿ-les-Roses
plusieurs citoyens spontanément ont
voulu encourager leur mère je viens vous
voir parce que j'ai envie de pleurer
avec
bien malgré lui Vincent Jean Brun et
l'homme politique du jour en France
la nuit dernière une voiture bélier a
défoncé le portique de sa résidence
avant d'être incendié poursuivi sa femme
et ses deux enfants ont pris la fuite sa
femme s'est cassée une jambe en courant
et sa fille ses blessures visages une
enquête a été ouverte pour tentative
d'assassinat un cap a été franchi dans
l'horreur à tweeter le maire de peuple
juste la chaleur à pied comme plusieurs
commerces de sa ville avaient déjà été
vandalisé cette semaine une inspection
des dégâts au marché public était déjà
prévu à l'agenda les actes de violence à
L'Haÿ-les-Roses ont choqué la classe
politique vous l'avez vu sur ce marché
de L'Haÿ-les-Roses il y avait marqué on
a vos adresses on va venir vous brûler
chez vous et bien c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait et je pense que la menace a
peut-être pas été prise suffisamment au
sérieux mais qui pouvait l'imaginer
même la première ministre Elisabeth
borne s'est déplacée par solidarité une
longue discussion s'en est suivie sur
balcon de l'hôtel de ville qui est
entouré de barbelés depuis trois jours
en France depuis 6 jours quel que 70
mairies auraient été soit vandalisés ou
incendie et la population est de plus en
plus frustrée face à ses attaques contre
les élus ou contre les biens publics
c'est triste parce que c'est avec notre
argent des concitoyens qui c'est nous
qui allons payer tout ça quoi moi
j'aurais pas hésité à déclencher pardon
couvre-feu et toi d'urgence voilà même
nous aussi on est embêté on effrayé
aussi par rapport à cet événement
donc il faut que ça s'arrête la
grand-mère de Naël tuée par un policier
implore les émeutiers de cesser leur
casse les Français sont invités à se
réunir symboliquement devant leur mairie
lundi avec l'espoir d'en finir avec
cette France barricadé
évidemment tout le monde espère que la
violence diminuera tout le monde se
croise les doigts bon la nuit n'est pas
terminée en France on verra ce qui se
passera au cours des prochaines heures
mais au moment où on se parle tout porte
à croire que le bilan des arrestations
de la nuit et des actes de violence
pourrait être moins élevé qu'au cours
des dernières nuits je peux vous dire en
tout cas que ce soit sur les
Champs-Élysées ça n'a absolument rien à
voir avec hier soir ou des dizaines de
personnes avaient été arrêtées en fin de
soirée pour l'instant c'est très
tranquille ce soir faut dire qu'il y a
toujours 45000 policiers sur le terrain
que le ministre de leur de l'Intérieur
leur a à nouveau demandé de faire preuve
de fermeté et vous l'avez vu dans mon
reportage il y a cette colère qui monte
au sein de la population on apprenait ce
soir que 220 villes ont été touchées de
près ou de loin par un acte de violence
le président Emmanuel Macron a convoqué
les maires de ses villes mardi merci
beaucoup Jean-Sébastien
à part et merci
[Musique]